Brazil's Supreme Court has begun issuing
sentences against rioters who stormed
top government offices on January 8 in
an event prosecutors have called an
attempted coup
the emblematic historic building where
we're meeting the facilities of the
National Congress and the panalto palace
the headquarters of the three pillars of
Brazilian democracy have been the target
of a discernible coup attack
the January riots were carried out by
supporters of former president jaid
bolsonaro in an alleged attempt to
restore the former president to office
Riders forced their way through security
barricades smashed windows and illegally
gained entry into several government
buildings some 1500 people were detained
among them ayesio Lucio Costa Pereira a
fervent bolsonaro supporter who was
captured on security camera donning his
shirt calling for a military coup and
praising others who participated
on Thursday Pereira was the first
offended to be sentenced by the court
by a majority of votes the plenary
rejected the preliminaries and judged
the criminal action precedent to
sentence the defendant Lucio Costa
Barrera to 17 years 15 years and six
months in prison and one year and six
months in detention and 100 days fine
Brazil Supreme Court is expected to hand
out more sentences in the days and weeks
ahead
this first decision is very important
for many different ways
one of that is because as its first
decision it will be guiding the next
decision about January 8 here in Brazil
in Brazil
Brazilian president Luis nacio Lula de
Silva has accused former president jaile
bolsonaro of encouraging the uprising
drawing parallels to the January 6 2021
assault on the U.S Capitol by supporters
of then-president Donald Trump
as the trial unfolds critics argue that
bolsonaro had sown doubt about the
reliability of Brazil's electronic
voting system without evidence
heightening tensions in the South
American Nation Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera